hello  [Music]  oh no  crashing eddie went back to the lost  world and i thought i made bad choices  hello boys but wild at your service our  [Music]  what  hero  you to to my world we want to live a  life of adventure like you it's a bad  time for a tropical vacation  everyone we face a grave threat can you  repeat that  i had a marshmallow in my ear  ah crashing eddie you've been gone a  while  shouldn't we just be looking for bones  at this point thanks sid  this is our chance to prove ourselves  boys what you lack in intelligence  destiny awaits  oh destiny hurts  you make up for him bumbling ineptitude  if we don't find them i'm gonna kill  them  [Applause]  [Music]  you